j'ai inventé cette histoire et je me
suis dit que ça ferait une belle
histoire
voilà je les écris on a fait un film
maintenant on va voir si les gens ça
leur plaît et si c'est le cas ils vont
venir s'il le voit s'ils n'aiment pas
ils vont dire leurs amis de ne pas le
voir et fin de l'histoire
je pense en fait que beaucoup de
mélodrame l'histoire mais pas le jeu du
film disposition musique très
sentimentale très dramatique
il ya tous ces différents éléments ont
souvent créé beaucoup d'émotion
antoine l'a dit c'est un film super mais
un peu barré et et c'est pas le seul à
pas avoir tout compris au film même le
délégué général du festival thierry
frémaux a pas tout compris et même vous
colline faisait pas tout compris
regardez qui appartient à cette
tradition des films on comprend pas tout
mais je voudrais impôts insisté sur le
revenu sinon je ne serais pas là à vous
faire part de mes sens tout en éveil
suite avant l'entretien avec vous dis
car si je vous dis allen vous me
répondez bien vous me répondez déjà ce
serait ma bhl
vous me répondez stewart konigsberg dit
woody ou dis donc qui vient cette année
présenter son nouveau film
irrational man que l'on pourrait
traduire par les par un traducteur ça
nous aiderait sylvie compris j'essaie de
sueur en fait ce film c'est une sorte de
film métaphorique sur le diktat de la
bourgeoisie qui essaient de nous imposer
la viande couple et c'est vrai que ça
c'est une des questions que se pose tout
nous les femmes
est ce que c'est important d'être un
couple pour être acceptée par la société
rachel à ce que vous en pensez ça c'est
de la question du christ alors moi je
laime pro viser un hlm accueillir et
bien ça je pense que ce n'est pas
uniquement une chose sociétale vous
savez même les animaux cherchent
également leurs partenaires dans la
nature
nous sommes des animaux finalement je
sais que nous avons des costards des
robes mais nous sommes tous des êtres
humains mais aussi des animaux à vous la
question sommes nous des animaux par
joaquin phoenix play off the hacker
phoenix je mets le rôle d'un philosophe
qui veut connaître en tant que
réalisateur vous avez envie quelquefois
de commettre des crimes tout le temps
tout le temps j'arrête pas je risque de
passer le reste les bagnes en prison si
je m'écoutais si vous deviez être un
animal qu'elle serait cet animal
répondez moi ça john chambers et un
chapeau et japonais l'oea a les bons pas
chers
un principe qui serait dans les mains
d'une petite fille aussi mignon c'est
mignon
coline serreau moins d'un mois et il y
en a une qui veulent juste au dessus de
votre tête
l'actrice célèbre extrêmement belle
membres du jury qui a monté les marches
et qui a créé le buzz parce qu'on a vu
sa culotte parce qu'en fait elle pensait
qu'on ne la voyait pas mais qu'en fait
tout le monde l'a vu et que du coup tout
le monde ne parle que de ça aujourd'hui
c'est c'est sophie marceau bien sûr
sophie marceau ici aux côtés de
guillermo del toro alors elle pense
qu'elle n'est pas filmé mais
malheureusement à cannes il y à des
caméras absolument partout c'est
terrible pour la comédienne mais
malheureusement c'est pas la première
fois que les marches trahissent cet
immense star du cinéma français
tout le monde se souvient de cette image
c'était il ya dix ans la bretelle de sa
robe s'était alors dérobé en même temps
il y a 20 ans sophie marceau nous avait
déjà montré sa chatte pierre quel est le
programme de ce soir sur la croisette en
projette mad max a lancé hier à mad max
ouais bah on leur passe et pourquoi pas
ses seuls fine qui fait du bruit qui
fait parler du festival
bon d'accord père et demain mad max
c'est pas possible
si si je vais passer mad max cinq fois
par jour toute la semaine comme dans un
vrai cinéma et avec ça on va
rentabiliser le festival
vous avez un point commun toutes les
deux c'est le mexique
vous avez passé quelques jours de
vacances il ya pas longtemps au mexique
vous avez posté d'ailleurs une photo sur
instagram à merci qu'on voit ici le
loyer et qui s'appelle coucher de soleil
ouais et c'est au mexique
seulement personne ne regarde le coucher
de soleil sur cette photo c'est les
scellés cactus quand les gars salma
hayek
on a remarqué quelque chose vous êtes
toujours habillé en rouge et noir ou en
rouge et en noir d'ailleurs vous portez
une robe noire ce soir dans le film vous
êtes en rouge et noir lors de la séance
photos qu'on appelle le photocall hier
vous étiez en rouge et en anglais sur
ces photos vous êtes en rouge en noir en
rouge en grandeur mais nous nous on sait
pourquoi vous êtes toujours orange et
noir j'aime ce que je fais couleurs du
club de foot de rennes mercier attendez
vous jouez une reine lors de la victoire
de rennes face au psg au parc des
princes est même fait un tour d'honneur
vous étiez la star
c était la star sa main